This morning, we're
learning new evidence
about the new
details about the evidence
that led to the arrest of Bryan Kohberger.
That is the man charged with mur
in the killings of four Idaho
College students.
The evidence includes
a, quote, collection
of dark red cuttings
from a pillow
with a reddish brown stain
in part of a mattress cover with
these were some of the items
taken from Coburg, his apartment
CNN's Jean Casarez joins us with
So this evidence, Jean,
was taken from these unsealed do
the search warrant documents.
Tell us more.
And we're also seeing the applic
which is fascinating
because their argument
to get this search warrant
at the
residence of Brian Kielburger
is that there was so much blood
at the crime scene
and there had to have been blood
and blood castoff,
and that had to get
on the clothes of the killer
and the shoes of the killer.
And based on
according to these documents,
they say based on the phone reco
and the locations
that he went afterwards,
we believe that he could have go
straight home after this.
And this is what we're asking fo
We weren't sure everybody
what they were asking for.
They asked for blood
or other bodily fluid.
Nine IVs, sheets or other sharp
images of the four students
that were killed
and data
showing any
planning that he might have done
or how to carry this off.
Now, let's show you what they to
And this is the return
from the search warrant affidavi
They took a collection of dark
red cuttings
from the pillow of reddish brown
a pair of mattress covers
with the stains,
several hair strands and animal
strand remember,
there was a dog, Caylee
had her dog there,
a nitrate type black glove
and store receipts, a Dickies ta
Dickies, of course, is a long
standing store for workwear.
Right.
And I looked on their website
a lot of dark clothes for the wo
but this is significant.
And also
they did some
presumptive testing at the scene
been in courtrooms for so many y
I can tell
you, is at the scene,
they can do a presumptive test
to determine if it might be bloo
and they took those with them.
So I think that's an indication
what presumptive testing
may have shown right there.
And then also,
I think the nitrate glove
is fascinating because
we know his DNA.
We know
the DNA of the killer
was on the knife sheath,
but it wasn't from a glove
because they got DNA
You can't get DNA from the glove
You get it from the finger. Righ
Or the hand or some body part.
So it's interesting
that they took that glove
we didn't see
in the search warrant affidavit
that any glove was found at the
but they thought
possibly we could get something.
What a fascinating list,
both of what they got
and what they were at.
Yes.
Jean Casarez,
thank you very much for that rep
Well, this now is criminal
defense attorney Ashley Merchant
Ashley, thanks so much for being
So you just heard that list
of what they got.
What do you think
the most important thing now
is that they have in their hands
the glove and the hair.
And I think the glove is importa
because if they can put
any of the victim's skin
cells on that glove,
maybe on the outside of the glov
they can also test for fingerpri
and skin cells
on the inside of the glove.
So if they could find their susp
skin cell on that glove or a par
print or a partial fingerprint
or something like that,
and then they've got the victim'
skin cells on it,
that's going to make their case
because that connects the two
and there's no other connection.
Why would a coworker be in that
Why would he have an item
that share skin cell?
The other thing
that I think is important is the
that the hair have any roots att
If it did, they can get DNA from
Did he have some transfer DNA
from those victims
that he brought home with him?
And so we're not just looking at
We're also looking for things
like transfer DNA,
because we're to the point in sc
that we can actually get DNA,
also skin cells.
And that's one of those things
that I mean, you can drop a skin
very easily.
If you shake someone's hand,
you transfer your DNA to their h
And so that's what
they're really looking
for, this trace type DNA
Ashley, we also know the code.
Berger's
lawyers waived his preliminary
hearing until June.
What, if anything, does that tel
I thought that was very telling.
Because that's not something
that we normally do
as defense counsel,
especially if we have a client
that we believe is innocent.
We want to have that hearing
as soon as possible
and they're allowed to have it
or they're actually required
to have it within 14 days.
And that's one of those hearings
that if they don't have enough e
your client goes free.
Your client
either gets a bond
or they're out
while they're trying to investig
So the fact that they waived thi
hearing up until June,
that isn't a very long time to w
the hearing.
That tells me
that they think
that there might be some more ev
And that also tells me
that they may be talking
with the prosecutor
about trying to resolve
this case somehow.